don't love that thank you so much
everyone for occasioning this dinner
tonight to welcome our three new
friends it's been many years since I
sought out The Treasure of Foggy
Mountain over the years I've been joined
by many Wayward Travelers dreamers gym
teachers who got too close to their
students guilty but uh
in my defense no no no we live in
harmony away from the Civilized world
but when we do need to go on Supply runs
into town we put on our skin masks to
seamlessly blend in Jesus Christ holy
I feel like that's way more
noticeable definitely no offense it's
okay look good most of us came here to
find the treasure a Foggy Mountain
eventually we all realized we don't need
treasure
all that matters is you me each and
every one of us which is why we go by a
simple guiding Mantra here all lives
matter I'm sorry did I did we say
something to offend you when did you
guys leave Society again 12 years
ago now it clicks just like now that's
very
racist racist well we're not trying to
all lives matter I feel like he knows he
knows definitely know all lives matter I
got a tattoo of it oh my god dude big
nobody else get
that